ils sont venus faire le plus de bruit
possible faire entendre leur voix
surtout en dehors des murs du tribunal
car ce n'est pas seulement le procès de
faucheurs volontaires qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui mais bien pour eux le procès
des ogm alors autant que les juges c'est
les citoyens que ces militants voulaient
alerter
on joue les apprentis sorciers avec
l'environnement il faut protéger nos
enfants on voit bien que de plus en plus
de problèmes de santé partout qui sont
créées par les pratiques agricoles
intensives épaule droite
donc là on se bat contre les ogm parce
qu'on sait qu'avec des études de fête
avec des animaux axionov et manger des
légumes transgéniques et ça crée des
tumeurs le 28 novembre 2016 67 faucheurs
s'en étaient pris à des parcelles
d'essai de colza rendu résistant aux
herbicides à marsannay à darois avant
d'occuper les locaux de dijon céréales
38 d'entre eux comparaissent depuis ce
matin plus une trentaine de comparer 100
volontaires qui ont été acceptées pour
une fois par les juges
lucien est l'un d'entre eux ce breton ne
regrette pas son action
je suis pas recommencer chaque joue on
aider
lanceur de d'alert on n'est pas des
malfaiteurs
on a fait ça par conviction en juillet
dernier la cour de justice européenne a
défini les variétés muté comme des ogm
malgré tout la ligne entre ce qui est un
ogm et ce qui ne l'est pas reste un
casse-tête pour les juristes du côté de
dijon céréales on assure que tout a été
fait dans les règles
y a pas d'eau gm en europe il ya pas d
ogm en france il ya pas deuxième sur la
coopérative la réglementation est assez
cadré pour cela donc non aujourd'hui
vraiment le procès c'est une orientation
sur des gens qui bafoue les lois qui
font avancer leurs idées en s'asseyant
sur les lois de la république
voilà simplement ce qu'on veut c'est que
justice soit faite la bataille de mots
et d'idées va désormais se poursuivre
dans le prétoire l'audience est prévue
pour durer de longues journées
quant au rendu du délibéré il est
attendu pas avant 2019